great hi my name is David vamos from PR
team management consultants I'm here in
Davos it regards to whether or not the
economy or the environment will win out
two thousand line I think the answer is
that probably it will but if he can all
make metrics fully captured the cost of
the environment then you would see some
of the contradictions that we face
disappear the other thing that's
absolutely critical in driving that
discussion forward as the extent of
which governments prepared to intervene
in the enterprise when you're looking to
look at things like logging when you
look at things like the exploitation of
water resources if you looked at
countless other environmental issues
you'd find that the role of governments
in producing transparent tradable
economically rational outcomes is
critical if we can get that right then
some of those contradictions are going
to disappear